[Music]
this morning on the dish a chef who
wants to change the way we view soul
food Todd Richards was born in Chicago
and loved the traditional dishes his
parents and grandmother cooked after it
moved to Atlanta he became a top chef at
four seasons and ritz-carlton hotels and
other top venues around the south before
opening Richards southern fried in
Atlanta now he's out with a brand new
cookbook sole chefs culinary evolution
and 150 recipes the prestigious Michelin
Guide says the book expands the
definition of soul food and gives a
glimpse of what it will be in the future
chef Todd Richards good morning and
welcome to the dish good morning thank
you for having me I'm a little bit
starstruck because you guys are talking
about me this looks amazing what are we
about to eat so potato croquettes are
the first dish there and my dad would
definitely love to see those and then we
have a peach salad wonderful peach salad
and then chicken I mean you can't have
chicken without beans and we have more
beans and then the blueberry fried pie
which is my absolute favorite dessert in
the entire book so let me you've always
been interested in food always my my
family I mean every single holiday was
always at our house and and birthday
parties and we would cook so much food
and the only requirement for people to
come over is to make sure they brought a
delicious dish this wasn't that good you
cannot come back honest-to-goodness the
way it is and it was really about how we
brought people together in my family and
it was always discussion around food and
how great a dish could be and how we
always wanted to celebrate you know each
other and that in that matter but what's
also rooted and the frugality of your
parents oh man my dad my dad would throw
anything away potato croquettes is the
perfect example you cannot make mashed
potatoes for two people or four people
you always have something left over so
you know again we refrigerate it
you'll make balls with them roll them in
breadcrumbs fry them and serve them just
with anything else and we never threw
anything away there's a recipe in the
book for a collard green ramen and it
became because my mom loved Chinese food
there was his dish he had with noodles
pork belly egg and scallions and my dad
said well if you're going to eat out
we have to heat something up that we had
already in refrigerator he would heat up
collard greens and put it right there
next to that rum and and that's how it
is a kid it's just a big bowl of ramen
with collard greens where I don't stop
love it something that you wouldn't
think necessarily to put together also
things that I wouldn't think of as
Chicago cooking so how did you become
soul food in southern cooking in Chicago
how does that my mom who was a very
brilliant person was getting her
master's and she sent me to live Rock
Arkansas to spend time with my aunt
while she was in school and then the
lady next door to me mrs. R know
everyone has a big minor neighborhood
and she was our big mom and she wouldn't
make the best plate of fried chicken
ever we didn't make it at home we only
went next door to eat it and she took
care of the entire neighborhood and just
seeing that track of how delicious food
how we incorporated a lot of those
dishes from the south into our own
cuisine at home really made for a
magical childhood did you ever think
about going back to Chicago and opening
up a restaurant you know you know again
if the government allows cloning more
than happy to it's it's it sounds
romantic it sounds really great idea to
do so eventually I know what I will do
it because I want to do it just not
right this second let me ask you about
we love music on this show and so do you
you're a sound track oh well it does I
mean like bacon frying has a sound track
it has a sound and if you listen to the
bacon and when it gets quiet you know
the bacon is ready and I always tell
people you never go into a restaurant
that is any good without any music you
can't imagine eating in the silent
restaurant that wouldn't make any sense
and then also when my family was you
know we had the music outside in the
backyard we had music different music in
the basement different music upstairs
doing all these celebrations and it just
brings all those senses our love of
people together so you've got a
soundtrack with each dish each dish and
there's a long playlist at the end of it
where I ask you to sign this dish I'm
drinking here that's part of our berry
rum cooler I mean this is unbecoming
Saturday morning you got
[Laughter]
as we toast you could have this meal
with anyone pastor present who would it
be it definitely would be with my
parents I think I love them so much and
recently my dad passed away Hey but he
got to see the book and and he saw all
the stories and then you know you open
the cover and you see all those pictures
of us growing up as kids those are the
two most important people in my life and
I love them together chef Todd Richards
thank you thank you so much I'm if you
want more on the dish and chef Todd
Richards you can head to our website at
CBS this morning calm you're here